caminar es la primera cosa que a un niño
o niña quiere hacer y la última a la que
una persona mayor desea renunciar
caminar es tan natural como respirar esa
es una frase de john watcher y caminar
es tan natural que incluso marca una de
nuestras fases evolutivas nosotros
empezamos a caminar muy parecido a la
manera en la que caminamos ahorita hace
casi 3.7 millones de años
desde entonces hemos ido caminando
partiendo de áfrica por europa hasta
asia cruzando por el estrecho de bering
llegando al continente americano y
caminamos hasta lo más sur del sur del
sur de américa después aprendimos a
navegar y seguimos conquistando las
tierras lejanas que estaban en las islas
pero todo caminando
hace 120 años se inventó el automóvil y
aunque revolucionó un poco la manera en
la que nos comunicamos en la que nos
transportamos nos acercó a algunos
productos que no estaban tan disponibles
para algunas personas nosotros ahora
hemos excedido el uso del auto
particular y como resultado hemos tenido
estas postales en muchas ciudades de
méxico de latinoamérica y del mundo
tener ciudades de este tipo nos ha
afectado en la calidad de nuestro
espacio público en nuestra calidad de
vida en general en la salud en la
seguridad y en la economía local
yo quisiera preguntar a los que están
aquí presentes cuántos de ustedes
llegaron caminando levanten la mano
bueno los que no levantaron la mano yo
me imagino que o se teletransporta aaron
del asiento de su auto al asiento del
teatro o aparecieron repentinamente del
camión aquí o si vinieron flotando de su
bicicleta o no sé cómo le hicieron pero
yo quisiera que hicieran la reflexión
ahora sí de cómo llegaron aquí todos
llegamos caminando en algún momento del
día todas las personas tenemos que
caminar no podemos prescindir de esta
acción para llegar a ningún otro lugar
pero no todos nos identificamos como
caminantes o como peatones
la carta mexicana de los derechos del
peatón un documento hecho por la liga
peatonal que es el colectivo nacional de
organizaciones que trabajamos por el
derecho de los peatones establece que el
peatón es el andante del espacio público
sin ningún tipo de distinción de color
de piel poder adquisitivo historial
crediticio edad
o género lo que sea todos aquí somos
peatones incluso también las personas
que se trasladan por medio de una silla
de ruedas o algo que les ayude a caminar
nosotros como seres humanos pues tenemos
una serie de derechos humanos entre los
que se destaca el número 13 que es el
del libre tránsito el libre tránsito
también está establecido en el artículo
11 de la constitución mexicana y incluso
también hay reglamentos y otras leyes
que nos dicen que nosotros somos libres
de caminar nosotros nosotros como seres
humanos como personas no nuestro auto ni
nuestra camioneta ni nuestro camión
nosotros entonces la ciudad debería
diseñarse en el tema de movilidad para
mover personas y no autos porque son las
personas las que tienen el derecho
irrevocable del libre tránsito por su
ciudad
méxico es un país democrático y la
democracia es la práctica de la igualdad
de derechos individuales sin condiciones
una de las cosas que reflejan la
democracia en las ciudades es el espacio
público y las calles son espacio público
entonces en este espacio público en
particular pues igual y no es tan
democrático porque una persona pues no
puede caminar entonces nosotros no
estamos diseñando las ciudades conforme
al derecho ni conforme a los reglamentos
ni conforme a lo que es justo en el
artículo 2 del reglamento un holgado de
tránsito y vialidad de la zona
metropolitana de monterrey
tenemos la pirámide invertida de la
movilidad en la que se prioriza a
quienes hacen menores emisiones al
moverse quienes ocupan menos espacio y
quienes representan un menor costo que
son los peatones después están las
personas que se mueven en bicicleta
luego usuarios del transporte público
después del transporte de carga porque
nos traen los alimentos
la economía y al final en el menor
espacio en el tengo listo de trabajo
está el vehículo particular entonces
nosotros deberíamos tener acceso o más
bien tenemos acceso al conocimiento de
estas leyes y estos reglamentos que nos
indican que deberíamos de ser ciudadanos
de primer mundo que utilicen también la
calle como como si estuviéramos en el
primer mundo esta idea que tenemos de
que es que nos las han dado en europa o
en otros lugares donde las calles están
bien no solamente la gente las usa como
se debe de usar nosotros debiéramos de
poder compartir la calle y de priorizar
a quienes son más vulnerables porque
como pueden visualizar ocupan menos
espacio hacen menos emisiones pero
también son la mayoría de las personas
pensando que en el estado de nuevo léon
solamente la mitad de los habitantes
tiene un auto la mitad de los habitantes
no tiene un auto pero también los que
tienen auto tienen que caminar algún
momento del día entonces son la mayoría
de las personas las personas que caminan
yo quisiera invitarles a que tengan este
proceso individual en el que puedan
desprenderse un poco de moverse en un
auto particular tal vez algunos ahorita
nos puedan imaginar llegar de donde
viven a donde trabajan o donde estudian
o donde hacen sus actividades en general
en un medio que no sea el auto
particular bueno pues empieza a
compartir tu auto empieza a compartir
los traslados empieza a usar el
transporte público aunque sea un día
luego empieza a moverse en bicicleta tal
de los fines de semana o tal vez cancela
el uso del auto todos los fines de
semana para que tú puedas disfrutar la
ciudad de otra manera
porque caminar es algo muy importante yo
creo muchos de ustedes han sido testigos
de una de las etapas más importantes de
la vida de otras personas
ya sea con sus hijos sobrinos sus
hermanos menores o cualquier tipo de
persona pequeña entre los 12 y los 14
meses tuvo este acontecimiento
importante de su vida que fueron sus
primeros pasos todos quisiéramos que sus
primeros pasos fueran en banquetas y
calles de este tipo y muchos podrían
imaginar que está banquete está en
alguna ciudad lejana o en algún país
este muy rico o algo así pero no estaba
banquete está aquí la tenemos aquí y si
la tenemos aquí la podemos ver aquí la
podemos empezar a replicar aquí en otras
colonias en otros barrios en otros
sectores en otros edificios esta maqueta
es el producto del trabajo de muchos
años de muchas personas pero también va
a ser el ejemplo para hacer mejores
calles tomando esta de referencia
a nosotros nos tocó jugar en la calle
nos tocó llegar con nuestros amigos en
la bici nos tocó el por las tortillas
tal vez uno que otro los presión pero se
tomaron de por vida cuando pero seguimos
caminando desde chiquillos y entonces
fue algo muy importante para nosotros
porque todos los niños dependen de un
aprendizaje experiencial y hay muchas
experiencias que solamente se tienen en
la calle experimentar que se siente
pasar del sol a la sombra de un árbol
saber que un árbol es brutal por el olor
que despide saber que las mariposas
migran en en primavera y en otoño porque
tú lo estás viendo en la calle conocer
distintos tipos de flores porque los
vecinos las tienen en la banqueta y otro
tipo de experiencias son necesarias para
nuestro desarrollo emocional nuestro
desarrollo social y en general para el
desarrollo de nuestras capacidades
pero justamente
la falta de lugares o espacios en los
que podamos caminar pues se relaciona
también con que este país tiene el
primer lugar debe ser infantil y el
segundo lugar en obesidad en adultos
también en lo local el estado de nuevo
léon concentra el 22 por ciento de los
choques en todo méxico es decir de los
32 estados de la república más de la
quinta parte suceden en este estado es
un estado muy inseguro no por cualquier
otra razón que se les pueda ocurrir
ahorita sino porque no estamos
compartiendo la calle con los demás
siendo que nosotros mismos también somos
peatones incluso a nivel nacional los
choques son la principal caso de muerte
en personas de 1 a 14 años los niños
están muriendo senos en las en las
calles
los niños deberían de disfrutar los
niños en la condición en la que estén
las banquetas las van a caminar van a
encontrar una aventura que hacer van a
pasar por las banquetas y lo que sea
esta niña no se le ocurrió que la
banqueta estaba rota y que no quería
caminar por ahí o que estaba sucia o
algo así simplemente iba caminando iba
aprendiendo iba disfrutando
y eso es lo que los niños quieren los
niños quieren disfrutar líneas quieren
espacio público los niños quieren vivir
su ciudad
nosotros estamos condicionados a un
habitáculo que nos lleva de un lugar a
otro y que nos está
nos están
aislando de todo contacto con otras
personas y de todos y de todas las
experiencias que podríamos encontrar en
nuestro camino
yo he tenido la oportunidad en el
[Música]
colectivo al que pertenezco a la
banqueta se respeta de dar una serie de
talleres en el que le decimos a las
personas que nos platiquen que les gusta
de caminar donde les gusta caminar y
cualquier otro tipo de experiencia que
haya tenido al caminar y lo compartimos
entre todos una de las personas que más
me llamó la atención que no fue la única
es una que me decía que más bien me
estaba describiendo su experiencia de
caminar en una postal como ésta estaba
escribiendo en una tienda departamental
las cosas que veía las cosas que
compraba y yo les decía no pero tú
plática me más experiencias de caminar
cuando cuando vas a otro lugar cuando no
sé cuándo vas a comprar otras cosas el
transcurso de tu casa esa tienda pues no
no sabía decirme por qué en todos los
lugares a los que llegaba
después pudimos convencerle de que
ampliar un poco la descripción y pues
bueno no llegó tan lejos llegó nada más
afuera de la tienda entonces siguió
describiendo el espacio que vive el
espacio que experimenta con un espacio
condicionado al consumo nada más esas
plazas comerciales están limitando la
vida pública la vida en el espacio
público pero nosotros tenemos que llegar
en auto tenemos que estar en un
estacionamiento sigas caminando pues es
básicamente inaccesible entonces nos
estamos hasta cierto punto engañando y
en vez de exigir el espacio público que
sería para todos y que no está
condicionado el consumo nos estamos
conformando con esto y yo creo que lo
más grave de esta persona y de esta
persona es que pues tenía ocho años
entonces
una persona de 8 años
sí
no merece tener estas experiencias en su
vida
debería de estar como sus otros
compañeritos pensando que le gusta
caminar por las vistas porque es
saludable porque de mariposas incluso
una niña una vez nos dijo que le gustaba
caminar porque veían mariposas pulpo
nunca supimos que eran las mariposas
pulpo pero la dibujó el esos colores
enamoradas y dijo a mí me gustan las
mariposas pulpo de seguro vio un insecto
que para ella era
híbrido entre mariposa de pulpo y pues
eso es lo que le gusta y esa es una
experiencia que ya tiene y que ella va a
aprender de eso y eso es lo valioso está
en el espacio público
y bueno nosotros nos dimos cuenta
eventualmente que para caminar pues no
solamente se necesitan las banquetas
hace poco tuvimos el congreso peatonal
en el que vino uno de los exponentes que
sean más ágil peñalosa que es director
de ciudades 880 que su idea principal es
que las ciudades deberían estar
diseñadas para que las personas de 8 y
de 80 años los pudieran caminar y así
todas las personas en el rango de edad
pues son bienvenidas a estas ciudades
una de las frases que decía es que
nosotros debiéramos ser guardianes de la
mayoría silenciosa que son niñas y niños
adultos mayores y personas vulnerables
entonces nosotros como ciudadanía activa
o como personas que quieren empezar a
activarse en su ciudadanía pues
deberíamos de empezar a pensar por
quienes no pueden ahorita tener una voz
activa en las decisiones de la ciudad ya
sea por su edad por su capacidad
económica por el tiempo que le dedican
al trabajo o algo así nosotros tenemos
que ver por la mayoría pero por la
mayoría que es la más vulnerable
y al final de cuentas tú vas
descubriendo que caminar te despeja
caminar te ayuda a pensar caminar te
ayuda a conectar ideas empiezas a
conocer tu ciudad en una escala
diferente puedes tomar mejores
fotografías
y pues bueno tal vez las condiciones en
las que nos encontramos no son las
adecuadas pero pueden mejorar solamente
hay que entender que pues eso va a
tardar porque pues vamos caminando
bueno tal vez algunas veces pensamos que
tenemos que hacer cambios radicales para
poder caminar a través de ellos lo que
sea pero no es tan difícil
hace poquito tuvimos la celebración del
día mundial de las ciudades en la que
los niños salieron disfrazados a pedir
dulces con sus vecinos y ocuparon la
calle no se ocupó desplegar el ejército
o gastar millones de pesos o reconstruir
la ciudad desde cero ni nada solamente
los niños y niñas salieron a la calle
con o sin sus papás pero todos vivimos
una noche muy segura porque había muchos
niños en la calle yo no sé a quién se le
ocurrió poner el día mundial de la
ciudad es el 31 de octubre pero creo que
fue la mejor idea de todas para cómo
hacer esta celebración
y bueno para finalizar parafraseando el
tratamiento de las palabras andantes de
galliano
la autovía de tener una mejor ciudad la
tenemos en el horizonte y nos va a
servir para caminar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]